fort pendant ce festival de cannes on se
souvient aussi de jardin du jardin ils
sortent de la voiture avec berline et
oss 117 oss 1001 oui oui parce que c'est
le rôle de père des deux filles
passaient un nouveau personnage il va
nous en parler là dans quelques instants
ça rend très jaloux le personnage de
jean dujardin oss 117 oss 117 alerte
rouge on applique mois avec la patte de
nicolas bedos ceux qui aiment les sept
mois vous allez adorer ça puisque là on
va regarder regardez regardez derrière
nous on va tourner la caméra regarder
s'il vous plaît il arrive dans une
renault
nicolas bedos qui étaient là en 2019
pour la paix les seuls jean dujardin qui
construit qui conduisait carrément la
belle époque on le rappelle le 8 minutes
en toscane innovation' voiture festival
qui m
nicolas bedos nicolas bedos pierre le
6ème art et gérer des stars qui vont
vers les fans ce que les fans son art
malgré tout ce qui s'est passé ils
étaient là tous les soirs signature
autographes selphy alors didier donc je
viens de dire l'eau